well certainly there's a few artists
like Gordon Meadowlark from the 70s
who's been really enormously influential
and my work I think since I was even in
college he's someone who who similarly
had something of a background in
architecture and whose work went off
into happenings and into his large-scale
sculpture projects actually involved
buildings but the removal of parts of
buildings instead of the addition of
like material let's say which is we can
eventually think of the sculptor or the
architect is adding material to the
world and I think what I'm so interested
in with his work in particular is these
cuttings he did building cuttings where
he would remove very strategically
pieces of buildings to make them
function in different ways or make you
understand them in different ways and
then he did a project called food in
Soho which was really nothing more than
a restaurant where artists would come
and cook and prepare food for other
people but it also was a venue for
activities and happenings that went way
beyond what you think of as a
conventional restaurant but i think his
work is is growing more and more
relevant I think in more and more
influential on on different architects
and artists practices today and I think
with this really important survey at the
Whitney this year it'll be interesting
to see how his work as influential on
generations of artists and architects
just coming of age now
you